hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast natural human gene knockouts
in the discovery of new drug targets I
am Judy Oracle glad roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring this educational web
seminar presented by lab roots we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this is an educational webinar and
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over and to
get your credits click on the c/e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like
introduce introduce today's speaker Rick
Dewey md head of translational genetics
at the Regeneron genetics center dr
dewey received his ad in chemistry and
physics from harvard university and md
with concentration in cardiovascular and
pulmonary sciences from stanford
university you receive clinical training
in internal medicine and cardiovascular
medicine at Stanford Hospital and
Clinics and research training and human
genetics via the Stanford clinical
investigator pathway his research work
has focused on gene discovery in
familial and complex cardiovascular
disease using high-throughput sequencing
and application of exome and genome
sequencing and clinical care he joined
the Regeneron genetics Center a wholly
owned subsidiary of regeneron
pharmaceuticals in 2014 and currently
leads the translational genetics group I
will now turn it over to dr. Dewey for
his presentation
I good morning and thank you Junie for
the kind introduction and to the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to talk about some of our work that
we've been doing at the Regeneron
genetic center focusing specifically on
natural human gene knockouts and the
application of exome and genome
sequencing for drug discovery purposes
thank you to all of you for tuning in
particular those folks on the west coast
for whom this is happening at quite an
early hour so today I'll talk a little
bit about some of the stark realities of
therapeutic development in 2015 2016 and
the ways in which whole genome
sequencing whole exome sequencing can be
leveraged to improve the discovery and
validation process for new therapeutic
targets will touch on some of the work
that we're going at three general
genetics Center and focused on a few
examples specifically within the lipids
and cardiometabolic space of the way in
which that we are leveraging whole exome
sequencing in particular in large
population spanning family based designs
for human genetic purposes all the way
through to large complex interrogations
of complex disease and in population
case control studies as well as large
clinical cohorts and we think are
emblematic of the promise of the
precision medicine initiative so the
reality of course in 2015 is that
increased investment in research and
development and the pharma industry has
not led to a dramatic increase in the
number of new molecular entities on the
challenge here of course in bringing
these molecules to market is that over
ninety percent of molecules that are
Phase one clinical trials fair to
demonstrate failed to demonstrate
sufficient safety and efficacy to
eventually gain regulatory approval and
make it to the patients that need them
most most of these failures are now
occurring in phase 2 clinical trials
fifty percent do you lack of efficacy
and a small proportion due to toxicity
and the challenge that we face is that
preclinical models that we've relied on
for decades and have espoused i'm here
Regeneron and in other places may be
poor predictors of clinical benefit it's
now been demonstrated that compounds
that are supported by human genetics
evidence
substantially more likely to succeed and
so one of the things that I'll talk
about today is the way that human
genetic evidence can be incorporated
into the drug target discovery and
validation process so there are numerous
examples of ways in which human genetics
have pointed the way either prior to
development of therapeutics or
subsequent to the development of
therapeutics to targets that are
efficacious in humans one of the
canonical examples so we've pointed to
in recent years has been that of pcsk9
and I'll see if I can use the corner
here to point that out which is a poster
child for the way in which human
genetics has pointed the way to a
therapeutic target based initially on
the observation I'll talk about this and
some subsequent slides that
gain-of-function mutations segregated in
individuals harboring autosomal dominant
presentations of familial
hypercholesterolemia a very severe early
onset form of high cholesterol that's
associated with substantial
substantially increased morbidity and
related mortality due to atherosclerosis
coat disease subsequent to that
observations made by Jonathan Cohen
Helen Hobbs and others solidify the
other end of the story or the other end
spectrum in which loss-of-function
mutations beneficial loss-of-function
mutations and large human populations
were found to confer favorable lipid
profiles and protection from
cardiovascular disease and this has
really spurred the development and a
race to the finish line now of three
molecules that target pcsk9 which
internalizes the LDL receptor thereby
reducing hepatic LDL mkay there are a
few additional examples of this now in
recent years including that of a plus c3
really starting with observations in the
Old Order Amish a founder like
population that by virtue of geographic
and reproductive isolation harbors
alleles at a surprising frequency
including the April lipoprotein be
mutation are 35 27 cube that is
associated with an autosomal dominant
form of familial hypercholesterolemia
in that population observations made by
Alan shoulder I mean others at the
University of Maryland I found a stop
mutation to premature stop mutation that
abrogates able to push a protein c3
function thereby reducing triglyceride
levels in humans subsequent to that a
number of investigators including state
kathiresan investigators Copenhagen ant
Edgar Hansen and Baron or discard were
able to demonstrate that these same
mutations and very large populations
confirm not only favorable reduction in
triglyceride levels but also
approximately forty percent reduced odds
of coronary disease and this is spurred
again anti-sense molecules to abled of a
protein c3 really opening the door in a
big way for triglyceride lowering
therapies that might have a beneficial
effect on humans with respect to anthro
sporadic cardiovascular disease do you
hear just summarizing again these two
stories in which the initial observation
often was made between a half and a full
decade prior to a clinical proof of
concept by which gain-of-function
mutations or loss of function mutations
that were associated with either
unfavorable or favorable norm clinical
manifestations in human populations
ultimately led to the development of
these two therapeutics the goal of what
we do is to really accelerate this
process by bringing the human genetic
discovery process in-house nested within
an early phase group among research and
development activities here at genron
and accelerate the process from initial
genetic insight to therapeutic
development and deployment within the
clinic so we have really three main
goals I'm here for human genetics that
of indication discovery that of new
target discovery by identifying new drug
targets and pathways via human genetic
observations and I'll tell you a few
stories about that related to
identification of our loss of function
mutations that confer a favorable
they could for a favorable a clinical
clinical profiles in human patients as
well as the identification of new
biomarkers to predict a response to
disease either adverse event official
and help to further stratify patient
populations to those that are most
likely respond favorably to our drugs
and these are the three tenets for the
way that we are using human genetics
here at regeneron to guide our drug
discovery development process our
leadership team here consists of valence
shell dinner again as I mentioned
earlier came to us from University of
Maryland marys Paris who has been a
longer time Regeneron employee and
previous to this was a Duke Ingrid
brekkie who just joined our team and
he's our analytical genetics group I
lead our translational genetics group
here at her Gendron and previously was
at Stanford Harris economy DSM who is
heading our functional modeling group
our goddess men who leads our clinical
informatics group and came to us from
Mount Sinai I'm a John Doe Burton and
Jeffrey who lead our sequencing and lab
operations and genome informatics groups
are respectively coming from Yale as
well as from el balon so the way that
we've been approaching the
identification of validation of new drug
targets I'm using human genetics is to
employ a multi-pronged approach in which
we fully espouse an approach in which
integrated human genetic studies across
genetic trait architectures from the
smallest family based studies of
individual segregating inhaling diseases
all the way through to general
population studies in which we are
gathering phenotypes more or less by
convenience from large clinical
populations will help us to fuel genomic
discovery I'll tell you a little bit
about the ladder and a we think of as a
ground bacon collaboration with the
geisinger Health System located in
central and northeastern Pennsylvania
many of you I'm sure have heard about
the precision medicine initiative
announced by President Obama on the
other part of last year which has
proposed a very bold goal of sequencing
approximately 1 million volunteers for a
research program which is very
a broad-ranging and this involves
linking genetic data to electronic
health records as one component of a
broad program that aims to personalize
the approach to medicine and really
improve the precision by which we
deliver care the primary ten years that
understanding how genomic variation and
other health factors influence human
health and disease can allow us to
better treat patients individualized
fashion and the goal here is to build a
very comprehensive knowledge base for
implementation of precision medicine
that we hope will not only improve our
understanding of the fundamental basis
of human disease enlarge our populations
but also perhaps for the development of
new therapeutics that are targeted to
specific populations we have what guy's
ear employed a or embarked on a very
similar program beginning really the
late phase of a 2013 and drawing on
their my code community health
initiative which is very ambitious by a
banking effort that has to date enrolled
over a hundred thousand individuals with
a goal of applying genomic based
interrogation to identify new levers the
drive disease as well as perform genomic
medicine implementation at a scale on
that has yet to be mashed anywhere else
and so we have a goal at this point to
sequence over 250,000 people within the
guise of your health system and build
what we believe to be one of the world's
most comprehensive genotype-phenotype
association resources using
de-identified clinical data from all
250,000 people 28 our drug development
in genomic medicine efforts guys will
tell you a little bit about some
subsequent slides but if it is a very
large integrated health system that
exists in central and northeastern
Pennsylvania and is advantaged for this
type of research by several things
including cradle to grave records for
over 2.5 million patients and
approximately 1.4 million of whom are
very active participants within the
health plan this is a very large
population-based study the names the
sequence over 250,000 participants and
integrate genetics with electronic
health record based clinical phenotype
information
the geisinger Health System as I
mentioned has catchment area which
exists in central and northeastern
Pennsylvania it aims to connect these
cradle-to-grave electronic health
records with genomic data primarily
exome sequencing and array-based
genotype and approximately 100,000 of
these patients have been consented to
date and approximately 60,000 have been
sequencing genotyped and our general
genetic center in addition to a large
unselected patient population there are
several targeted recruitment efforts
including efforts to engage participants
in a car do genomics protocol enrolling
patients from a cardiac catheterization
lab where a geographic data about the
coronary Anatomy as well as
physiological data about partying about
cardiovascular function as well as a
large ascertain via the bariatric
surgery clinic on which is the largest
one of the largest research studies of
its kind in the United States the guise
of your health system as I mentioned is
advantaged by being one of the earliest
adopters or electronic health records in
the united states adopting the epic
platform in 1996 and having a relatively
stable patient population in which the
participants in their health plan
receive all of their primary and sub
specialty care on be in the health
system and so this is a relatively
complete accounting of their medical
care that is captured in electronic
health records that we identify let me
i'm receive it D identified forms of why
the sequencing at scale required for
this type of effort for what we are
focusing on which is functional coding
variation within predominantly exonic
regions of the genome turns out that
this variation not surprised anyone has
been involved in the size for some time
as exceedingly rare and so this is some
data describing sequence variants
identified using whole exome sequencing
of the first 50 thousand participants in
the discover program that we've embarked
on together with geisinger in which
you'll appreciate the
a site frequency spectra here on the
right that more functional variation in
particular loss of function variation is
enriched for exceedingly rare alleles
approximately fifty percent of the
variation that we are observing of this
class occurs only once within the data
set we discovered approximately four
million single nucleotide variants and
approximately 220,000 search and
deletion events on the protein-coding
regions of each of these 50,000
individuals genomes and approximately
hundred and seventy five thousand
predicted loss-of-function variants
thereby producing a vast reservoir of
functional variation for us to
interrogate with respect to its effects
on clinical phenotypes within this group
of individuals again not surprising data
this has been observed by others on
include a MacArthur and folks who have
been involved in the excellent
aggregation consortium study but each
discover participant here Harper's
approximately 20 predicted
loss-of-function variants the majority
of which occur in heterozygous state and
approximately one rare homozygous loss
of function variant has been observed
her individual other by providing again
a vast reservoir for predominantly
heterozygous observations in terms of
their association with our clinical
phenotypes what is a the coverage of
gene regions look like with loss of
function variants as a sequence deeper
into this population here we have the
accrual of loss of function variation as
a function of population size on a
purging basis and what you'll observe is
that even at the sample size we have we
have near complete coverage of autosomal
protein coding genes or loss of function
variants and one or more individuals in
heterozygous state and approximately
forty-seven percent of jeans and at this
sample size our Harbor heterozygous
mutations and twenty or more individuals
providing a resource at least for
quantitative trade association testing
and increasingly now for binary
treatises
asian test and to identify disease
associations that might be that might be
a good mimic of what antibody blockade
or other therapeutic antagonism I might
do in a human connecting this of course
the clinical phenotype data is really
what is necessary for phenotypic
Association discovery so here's just a
very very high level view of a geyser
clinical data warehouse which is a live
phenotype database in which we receive
clinical phenotype information on a
rolling basis this is a very large
repository of information with
approximately 40 tables 1.5 billion rows
that grows by 308 million rows excuse me
that includes 308 million rows of lab
results and grows by 520,000 our rows
per week this database is representing
the identified fashion as they had back
end to epic and we received others
clinical information and concert before
geisinger colleagues transforming its
binary and quantitative traits that
allow us to do association testing or
genetic data just again another top line
summary of the clinical data housed
within the geisinger Health System there
a very large number of high-quality HR
drive phenotypes that are available for
discovery purposes you'll note that on
the top left here that a the median
number of or the median amount of data
within the healthcare system here is
approximately eight years of data for
each participant that's been sequenced
common things being common within this
health care system we have a very
abundant representation of relative
common complex diseases including
hypertension hyperlipidemia coronary
artery disease keep myocardial
infarction and the like and relatively
abundant representation of laboratory
values with repeat measures that allow
us to understand over the course of a
lifetime the genetic influences that
determine laboratory and other traits
and within that the healthcare system as
a supplement to what's been gathered in
the course of
routine preventive care we also have
trait values that cover other ancillary
data sources including choreography
electrocardiography ocular measures pfts
dexa data unlike and all of this really
makes us a very rich repository of
phenotypic information for association
discovery hope can drive on so as proof
of principle I'm showing you here the
associations between loss-of-function
variants and genes that encode lipid
lowering drug targets and here hoping to
convince you that they recapitulate the
established pharmacological effects of
these drugs including things that are
currently in early phase and early
phases of clinical development including
18 ATP citrate liason hitters a story
i'll tell you a little bit about here in
subsequent slides around an inhibitor of
NGO point in like three which is an
endogenous inhibitor of lipoprotein
lipase and we've observed here is that
nearly all of our targets Harbor
loss-of-function variants which at least
nominally according to ominously
thresholds recapitulate the drug effects
of therapeutic antagonism of these
targets and human populations we've been
able to subsequently evaluate some of
the targets that are currently in our
early phase discovery or development
pipelines and here I'm going to show you
some data around eh PTL for which is an
adopt and endogenous inhibitor of
lipoprotein lipase lipoprotein lipase is
one of the canonical enzymes involved in
triglyceride metabolism and acts and
various tissues to petition free fatty
acids to oxidative and storage tissues
according to metabolic need in concert
with our geisinger colleagues we
evaluated the relationship between a
low-frequency missense mutation in HPT
04 the e 40 k mutation which has been
previously demonstrated to abrogate the
ability of HP tail forked and hit
lipoprotein lipase as well as other
putative loss-of-function mutations that
I that were found within our cohort and
associated with lower levels of
triglycerides at higher levels of HDL
see what's been clear from previous work
is that these mutations are robustly
associated with triglycerides and HDL
levels or what has been less clear is
whether or not that lipid profile to
translate into a reduction in a thorough
squat at cardiovascular disease risk and
so we asked that specific question both
of the e 40 k mutation as well as of the
heterozygous and activating mutations
that we observed within our data set and
font and found that the e 40 k mutation
among approximately 10,000 corner order
disease cases to find a geographically
in approximately 30,000 master controls
was associated with about twenty percent
reduction in the odds or coronary artery
disease and heterozygous inactivating
mutations were associated with a more
dramatic reduction in on some corner of
artery disease thereby providing
additional lilyc evidence that
antagonism our genetic antagonism of age
PTL for might be beneficial with respect
to anthro erotic cardiovascular disease
and also I think providing some
additional evidence that modulation of
triglycerides might have a beneficial
and potential causal effect and
reduction of cardiovascular disease
residents we subsequently extended that
observation to antibody treatment in
non-human primates as well as in mice
were homozygous for the humanized form
of the h pto for gene that's the piano
here a here on the upper left in which
antibody treatment of these individuals
mice was associated with pretty
substantial reduction in triglyceride
levels and then among cynomolgus monkeys
on high fat diet as well as a rhesus
monkeys with hyperlipidemia antibody
treatment was similarly associated with
substantial reductions in your
glycerides interestingly antibody-based
inhibition of HPT 04 appears to reduce
triglycerides to near normal levels
despite or irrespective of the starting
point for triglycerides so in a single
monkey was severe hypertriglyceridemia
here in the lower right-hand panel we
observed a reduction in triglycerides
from approximately 2000 milligrams per
DL to near normal levels suggesting that
this might be highly efficacious for
even the most severe forms of hyper
triplets around Union we've then
extended this observation to one in
which we asked the question about you
40k and risk of type 2 diabetes here
showing data from our population the
geisinger Health System population and
approximately 11,000 type 2 diabetes
cases to find via an electronic health
record based algorithm that incorporates
diagnosis codes medication use and
laboratory values as well as now in
approximately 62,000 ditional cases in
two hundred ninety thousand additional
controls I robust association between
the 40k mutation and reduced risk of
type 2 diabetes perhaps providing a link
between triglyceride metabolism and
insulin sensitivity or insulin release
that demonstrates a benefit both for
triglyceride lowering and reduction of a
thorough sporadic cardiovascular disease
risk as well as reduction of type 2
diabetes and improved glycemic control
we've been able to use our in-house
amounts of resources to again confirm
this observation here showing on the
left-hand panel that glucose fasting
glucose levels in 57 black mice black
black six mice were deficient for the
inter PTO for gene were approved in
comparison to wild-type mice and
subsequently that oral glucose challenge
as well as insulin tolerance testing I
demonstrated improved glucose improved
insulin sensitivity and improved
postprandial glucose tolerance and these
mice perhaps demonstrating that HP tours
is mechanistic relate to
temperate glucose control this is
intriguing because this is one of the
first things that we are aware of that
when it activated in humans leads to a
combined effect on reduced odds of that
type 2 diabetes and reduced risk of
adverse cardiovascular disease and we
think might represent a very intriguing
target with respect to metabolic disease
risk reduction in humans one of the
concerns around therapeutic manipulation
of HPT l4 has been an observation that
that in HPT 04 deficient mice or
antibody treated mice and non-human
primates fed a high-fat diet had
developed mesenteric lymphadenopathy
which in the case of upto 4 deficient
mice had been severe enough to lead to
kyla societies and in some cases fatal
care tinnitus one of the intriguing
questions is whether this pre clinical
observation will translate to humans and
this is a critical concern to us as we
consider whether or not to push forward
the HPT l4 molecule as a therapeutic
target and it turns out that we have a
relatively reasonable number of
homozygous for the k 4 e mutation which
abrogates the ability to inhibit
lipoprotein lipase that are walking
around free living within the guys in
your health system and the ability to
interrogate what they look like from the
standpoint of clinical concerns than
Endeca I the abdominal and fatten up
with you and other abdominal pathology
seen preclinical models what we've been
able to observe thus far at least from
electronic health record based codes is
that they do not appear to manifest
icd-9 codes that correspond to the
sorters of limp of the lymphatic system
ascites peritonitis or even more general
abdominal complaints at a higher rate
than non-carriers within our population
and importantly in in deeper chart
review of these individuals five
incidentally had CT abdominal imaging
and four or five on that imaging study
had explicit mention of normal abdominal
lymphatics and 105 had no mention of
abdominal on lymphatic abnormalities
this thereby i think is an intriguing
set of observations that once
potentially validates the
as a drug target for metabolic disease
risk reduction in humans and raises the
question of whether this is
therapeutically approachable even in
light of the preclinical findings in
non-human primates and mice one of the
advantages of the geisinger Health
System collaboration is the ability to
perform genotype based callback studies
given that these individuals are all
consented for that activity and that's
something we are currently designing we
have a related molecule that's currently
entering the clinic that targets in
gpoint leg 3 which has been found in
kindred segregating familial combined
hyperlipidemia absent they have had a
triglyceride accumulation that is
typically associated for familial a beta
or hyperlipoproteinemia what has been
clear for previous work is that HP tl3
loss-of-function mutations both in large
populations as well as in families some
work done by need insulin and colleagues
as well as by Jonathan Cohen and Helen
pops again have been associated with a
combined hyperlipidemia profile that
canonically involves depression of all
lipid fractions HDL LDL as well as total
cholesterol as well as triglyceride rich
lipoprotein levels what has not been
clear again is whether or not that
translates into Chronicle benefit and
this is a lot most important as we move
our HP tl3 i'm inhibitor into the clinic
we are now I think reasonably confident
that the HP tl3 loss of function
mutations at least in the geisinger
population are associated with lower
odds of a thorough erotic cardiovascular
diseases to finding a geographically
here demonstrating an odds ratio of
approximately our point six
demonstrating about forty percent
reduction and odds and coronary disease
similar to that in our cohort observed
four in four pcsk9 loss-of-function
mutations these variants if identified
now approximately 12 of them are
associated with an approximate haven't
of circulating HPT of three levels as is
consistent with full walls of one allele
as well as an approximate twenty percent
reduction in triglycerides seventy
percent reductions in HDL and LDL
respectively which are highly
statistically significant and this has
translated despite the HDL effect into a
reduction in odds of taping of corner
our jerseys in our cohort if confirmed
externally I think this presents an
intriguing opportunity for us as we
consider positioning the entropy tl3
therapy not only for
hypertriglyceridemia as well as for
other forms of this lib edenia cell
transition now just briefly to some of
our efforts for target discovery from
target validation and show you some
selected examples of loss of function
varied associations with disease and in
this particular case you know providing
some evidence that we could recover even
things that are canonically thought of
as being our medallion expressions of
disease within large clinical
populations namely loss of function or
excuse me truncating variants within
Titan which are robustly associated with
primary cardiomyopathy within our cohort
brca1 associated with hereditary breast
and ovarian cancer not to associate with
inflammatory bowel disease nf1 associate
with neurofibromatosis in a host of
other disease conditions that really
light at the intersection between what
we could typically think of as mono Jana
growl ago genetic disease and complex
disease traits we have a few other
observations that we're currently
tracking down but our novel that are
potentially quite impactful from the
standpoint of developing therapeutics
including one that appears to be
associated with reduced odds of
alcoholic liver damage as I mentioned
the discover collaboration with the
geisinger Health System is really dual
purpose we have a primary interest in
using this data resource for a drug
target validation and drug target
discovery geisinger has I would say an
equally important interest in
understanding what genomic medicine
implementation might look like 21st
century and so really to address this
particular question what if everybody's
genome is available in their medical
record and so they've embarked on a
very old initiative to engage
individuals within the discover program
enrolling in the my code Community
Health Initiative who are harboring
mutations that appear to be clinically
actionable on the basis of on the basis
of clinical presentation pattern of
inheritance and the opportunity for
early clinical intervention that might
mitigate to morbidity mortality in this
population as I mentioned the population
is one that is stable and has lived here
for several generations in many cases
and also has substantial familial
substructure and that leads to some
interesting observations about alleles
that segregate within families here in a
way that might not be expected
completely unrelated population and so
here is one example of that for one of
the 27 disease conditions for which the
geisinger return of results effort the
genome first program has been designed
namely familial hypercholesterolemia
we've identified a large exonic
duplication the LDL receptor that
appears to be segregating in individuals
displaying the familial
hypercholesterolemia like phenotype in
reconstructing these pedigrees from
genetic information alone we've
identified a recent common ancestor
approximately six to seven generations
ago within the geisinger Health System
links all of these individuals these
individuals here have very early onset
cardiovascular disease and very high
levels of total and LDL cholesterol on
the place then that substantially
increased risk for the development of
heart attacks and other cardiovascular
disease conditions such as heart failure
subsequent to heart attack and there's a
pretty substantial opportunity for early
clinical intervention in the form of
highly efficacious lipid-lowering
therapy so one of the primary programs
here is to engage these individuals and
understand what early clinical
intervention and early identification of
these patient populations might yield in
terms of Chronicle benefit for this
group and so I'm showing you now some
data on the prevalence of familial hyper
Australia is defined clinically as well
as from on the basis of genotype alone
via mutations and LDL receptor the
lipoprotein be gene as well as pcsk9
than the geisinger population and which
we've identified I think it higher than
had been previously appreciated
prevalence genotypically at familial
hypercholesterolemia in this population
with approximately 1 and 215 individuals
here harboring a mutation that has been
canonically associated with from Myrtle
hypercholesterolemia not surprisingly
there's a higher prevalence of
individual of these mutations among
individuals answer kangy of the cardiac
catheterization lab with about one and
214 individuals ascertained via that
setting harboring imitation one of these
genes that has been economically
associated with neural
hypercholesterolemia as has been
previously demonstrated by others the
presence of severe hypercholesterolemia
is in itself not sufficient for the
diagnosis of a familial form of our
fiber cholesterol amia or some very
severe hypercholesterolemia here and
this is demonstrated by the observation
that among individuals with ldl-c levels
above 190 which would not qualify as
severe hypercholesterolemia only one in
40 of those individuals within our
healthcare system harbors a mutation in
one of the canonical are from Ohio close
for anemia genes turns out that the
gaean type based refinement of clinical
clinical recognition of this disease can
certainly increase the can certainly
improve diagnosis and so among
individuals were very positive there's a
higher proportion of individuals in the
clinical criteria or for familial
hypercholesterolemia and this is of
course important because of the
observation that
that genetically identified patients
with metal hypercholesterolemia have
about four and a half fold increased
risk for premature cardiovascular
disease which is highly statistically
significant and then among individuals
who present early with cardiovascular
disease there's an approximately 10-fold
increase in risk associated with the
presence of one of these mutations I'm
in this population that appears to be
independent of the level of total LDL
cholesterol there by suggesting that
there's a substantial opportunity for
early intervention here within this
population on the basis of genetic
information that can improve clinical
care ifemelu hypercholesterolemia is not
often adequately treated within this
population only 61 percent of genetic FH
patients in our cohort were on statin
therapy and at their most recent
encounter and only thirty percent had
achieved LDL cholesterol goals of less
than 100 milligrams per deal which is
consistent from with some emerging data
around clinically identified patients
enrolled it enrolled in the Cascade
registry how that has been put together
by the familial hypercholesterolemia
Foundation as a supplement to what we're
doing within the guise of your health
system we have a pretty substantial
focus on familial sequencing or
sequencing of families that are
harboring a rare apparently monogenic
conditions including own material
hypertension familial cardiomyopathy
early onset severe obesity and type 2
diabetes we view this as a primary
engine that is relatively high yield for
novel disease gene discovery and can
really sort of illuminate fundamental
human disease biology one sort of
canonical example of that put together
in collaboration with Wendy Chong at
columbia university in claudia gonzaga
Reggie who's been leading our medallion
efforts here at regeneron genetics
center is the implication of TB x4 now
in multiple individuals with a parent
familial forms of pulmonary arterial
hypertension and early devastating
disease in which there's high pressure
and the pulmonary vasculature that can
lead to heart failure and
mentality TBS for has been identified
previously in the context as well
patella syndrome and there have been
some early insights and suggests that
this might be it might be a gene that
plays a role and the development of
polymer material hypertension here
Claudia and Wendy had been able to find
some solid evidence via segregation
multiple families that a rare
deleterious parents and TV x4 are an
important cause of early-onset on the
retail hypertension perhaps the most
important cause aside from our
communications in bmp-2 so you're just
some additional data sort of on that
point which approximately eleven percent
of our cohort harbors mutations in TV x
for making it the second most impactful
gene and early onset Palmateer
hypertension farmer-owned being care to
i mentioned earlier the work that out
Sheldon or others have done in studying
the Old Order Amish we believe that this
is a high yield approach for knowledge
gene discovery in which taking advantage
of genetic homogeneity principles of
drift as well as recent population
bottlenecks which by virtue of
geographic and reproductive reproductive
isolation from these populations allow
certainly else to drift a higher
frequency and by a virtue of some degree
of endogamy within these populations
allow them to exist in homozygous state
we have an ambitious program to put
together a consortium of these
populations we have termed drift
discover research investigating founder
population traits led by Alan shell
dinner here at the urgency in which we
have embarked on a two tiered approach
to study these populations which
individually are homogeneous but we hope
to amass a heterogeneous menagerie of
these populations the first year
involves defining a real expect term
within and across these populations to
identify interesting functional variants
that might exist at higher frequency in
these populations than others and
interesting collections of homozygous
that can be studied further with respect
to phenotypic expression of traits of
interest for us the second tier would
involve genotype-phenotype Association
discovery
especially for these mutations that are
highly functional that are rich in a
given population and the engagement of
these populations in the genotype first
manner via if you take a call back
stones our foundational partner here is
the Old Order Amish and we have a very
rich collaboration with the clinic for
special children she'd buy homes Martin
now run by Kevin Strauss and Erich
puffin burger which is which is both
served clinically this population in the
Mennonite population and also has
engaged them research efforts and which
they've been very Welling participants
to engage in genomic studies of their
population to understand the fundamental
basis of devastating diseases among
among their people we also are embarking
on the collaboration with the Old Order
Amish community how much research clinic
right out of university of maryland
which is specifically positioned to do
in depth via terrible realization of
that population just a specific example
of the way in which World Order Amish
demography has increase in the number of
some minor allele homozygotes the about
3.5 percent of each Amish genome is
Otto's auto Saiga's here on there's
finite population size and this results
in some degree of endogamy Sox pencil
inity and the example here in the low
right as one in which allele has drifted
from one percent frequency to five
percent frequencies in the Amish and by
virtue of endogamy minor allele
homozygous a frequency has increased and
are approximately forty fold so we were
recruiting a for this and so if there
are those of you out there who have
studied these populations or have access
to these populations and are interested
engaging with us in large-scale genetic
interrogation of these groups you're
you're more than willing to participate
in research collaborations by which you
and we both benefit from the study of
these groups so just to sum up you know
human genetics have been integrated
across our discovery and development
pipelines here Regeneron we really
fundamentally believe this can change
the way that drug development is done
and we do sort of drink the kool-aid
with respect to the use of drug of
precision medicine and genomic
discoveries and in drug development and
believe that genetic experiments of
nature can point the way to his new
therapeutic targets and guide our drug
development efforts fundamentally
espouse a and approaching which
combining these approaches across
genetic trait architectures and
phenotypes can help catalyze discovery
and you know integrate this of course
across functional biology genomic or
functional genomics and clinical
pharmacology to drive our translation of
discoveries into therapeutics our
guiding principles of course here
involve the study of our general
populations the integration of both
Mendelian genetics and family based
studies with studies and founder
populations and other disease specific
and clinical cohorts at the phenotype
and coupling that with a very deep
phenotypic data including longitudinal
data as well as quantitative traits and
then emphasizing large without coding
variation as one way in which we can
provide some highly interpretive all
common sense challenges of course and
our early efforts have been the power to
detect rare variant associations is of
course hindered by a very rare
functional alleles and thus you know
large data sets are required for very
for both early discovery efforts as well
as replication efforts of our knowledge
and discoveries and river interpretation
including a sense of non-coding
mutations it remains a substantial
challenge most of the variation that
have come out of the gyc are existent
non-coding regions and I'm sure you hear
more about ways in which we can
functionally interpret that in the
course of the program here today but it
does remain a challenge with respect to
identifying functional units that might
be approachable therapeutically we've
had to develop de novo methods to handle
emerging computational challenges
associated with very large both Fiat
and genotypic data sets including new
ways of representing on the graphically
that allow us to rapidly traverse both
phenotypic and genotypic information and
perform association discovery and then
of course plugging this in to a pipeline
that is impedance matched to our
discovery efforts with respect to
functionally interrogating and
understanding these human genetic
associations is of utmost importance as
we drive these insights to translational
opportunities and potential therapies
lots of people to acknowledge the
development of this effort including a
wonderful team here at the regeneration
etic Center which is includes both
analytical translational scientists as
well as a heavy informatics support from
Jeff Reed steam our leadership team here
to earlier our collaborators who without
whom none of this work would be possible
at geisinger columbia and now 19 other
collaborating groups that have worked
with us to really drive for Heba genetic
work that we do here at the RTC and
especially to the thousands of patients
volunteers collaborators investigators
some who've worked more or less
anonymously with us a long way to drive
this work for so thank you very much for
your attention this morning tuning in
and I'm happy to take questions in this
phone thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is do you have any
efforts to perform hello typing and
examining the allele specific expression
in your 250,000 cohort
very interesting question certainly
haplotype specific effects parent of
origin effects and phasing as in Korean
guy I think are increasingly important
as we go beyond observations of the
heterozygotes within our data set we do
have ongoing efforts to develop
technology specifically to molecular
face and computationally phase our data
it made it again by the fact we have
substantial familial sub structure
within our cohort that allows us to
phase many of these alleles by
transmission with respect to Leo
specific expression on there are efforts
underway to perform sequencing-based
expression profiles of interest to us
and coupled with that you know those
specific expression I think is one way
in which we can gain insight to the
expression of some of the more
deleterious alleles that we find in our
in our data set
what about CHD genetic variants and
other people and groups or discussing
your data have all groups do do you
Jeannie would you please repeat the
question
what about CHD genetic variants and
other people in groups or discussing
your data have all groups so that the
guise of your data is predominantly from
individuals of European ancestry which
we believe is one view of the slice of
alleles that exists within humans that
can be used for Association discovery
and what's respected phenotypes we have
attempted to supplement that with other
specific collections that have included
other ancestral groups including large
East Asian collection that is being
sequenced in collaboration with with IDA
chana Jerry Rotter at the Los Angeles
biomedical Institute these are
individuals of probably at Taiwanese
ancestry what about hematological health
conditions as I didn't see the field in
discover so I believe the question was
here again about CTP inhibition and the
apparent failure of CTP clinically and
that is something that we are currently
investigating i would say that we don't
have a clear answer yet with respect to
the effect of CTP mutations of the
relationship to coronary artery disease
in particular sort of a canonical way in
which we hope that we can leverage human
genetic data to answer a critical
clinical question which is you know does
the HDL lowering an LDL excuse me HDL
increase in LDL lowering effect are are
associated with reductions in anthro
strata cardiovascular disease
does your data still correlate with the
apparent failure of cetp sorry that
question go there with me one second
does your data still correlate with the
apparent failure of cetp clinically Judy
thanks I think I answer that question
out of order here that's something we're
still investigating at this point the
answer isn't clear
while genetics may indicate whether an
individual is predisposed to a condition
could you please address what other
markers may indicate imminent onset of a
disease for example epidemia very good
question so of course genetics isn't
everything with respect the development
of disease and in fact in most cases
that explains only a very small
proportion of either variants and a
trait within human population or
variants and the risk for disease what
we have attempted to do in our studies
is to you know understand which
genetically vers drive that small bit of
variation and from there make the leap
to you know whether or not there
translational opportunities that might
emanate from manipulation of those
particular gene products within the
geyser population in addition to the
sequenced cohort we have access to
clinical phenotype information from
approximately 1.4 million participants
in their health plan there are
opportunities that fall from that to
understand epidemiological and other
relationships between environmental and
other factors that help not a
discernment determine disease onset and
that's a little bit of active interest
for guys you're in particular
why don't you use the TV x 44 gene
implication I'm sorry why would you use
the TV x 44 gene implication arterial
hypertension I think if I understand the
correct understand the question
correctly there's a question about the
relationship between tbx for and partner
Darryl hypertension within our family
based studies in this particular case we
observed multiple individuals
segregating TV x four mutations were
also affected by poner to hypertension
that segregation pattern was consistent
with causality for this particular gene
I'm within that within that disease case
has the geisinger system leverage stated
to apply pharmacogenomics guys here is
absolutely developing platforms that
will use genetic information to guide a
pharmacological therapy you know
canonically referred to as
pharmacogenomics and one of the
challenges there is is whether you know
is to identify the right way to
incorporate pharmacogenetic information
into routine clinical care in such a way
that is not disruptive at that corporal
care and also has a substantial enough
impact on these endpoints to make use of
that information meaningful there are
guidelines fortuitously that have been
developed for pre-existing clinical
information excuse me for pre-existing
genetic information in the way that that
can be used to guide pharmacological
management patients the see pic
guidelines that I would refer to you to
that least formalized on the way in
which this information can be
incorporated geisinger is currently the
process of considering how the best way
to deploy that
in the systematic ascertain mathon
founder population studies did you find
first or second tier harder to study and
gather information from very good
question the the second to your studies
involve a gathering in depth a clinical
phenotype data from these participants
and so that is you know has been more
challenging collaborate mode of
collaboration for us to engage in and I
think that that is something we hope
will you no will will improve as we
sequence deeper to these populations
find oranges and collections of these
alleles does the geisinger database have
care type testing data outside of the
routine clinical applications of
karyotyping we do not routinely perform
karyotype testing on the participants
and the discover population
what happens to the database of
volunteers who may have died during the
data collection the death could be
attributed to the gene being observed or
the volunteer might have died naturally
on track that's a comment or question
interesting question the volunteers who
have passed during the study and have
you know consented to the use of their
genetic and clinical phenotype
information continue to be used in the
course of the study for phenotypic
Association discovery one of the most
challenging things to do is to identify
genes that are six equal longevity which
could be a corollary to your question
here and that has been a long run for
many folks who have attempted to find
single leavers as it turns out probably
has to do with multiple genes are
contributing to both the development of
complex disease traits that are are
associated with with longevity as well
as the ability to survive those those
complex traits
how drastic were the changes from 2003
to 2015 there were very drastic changes
from 2003 to2015 2003 remind everybody
was you know right around the time that
the draft teen jack human genome was
declared complete since that time of
course there have been numerous
technological advancements that have
reduced the cost and increase the
throughput of human DNA sequencing
facilitating the development of genome
sequences now for tens of thousands of
people in exome sequences for hundreds
of thousands of people which was an
effort that for one individual for the
human genome project required
approximately ten years and hundreds of
millions of dollars looks like we have
time for one last question is there any
way to repair genetic mutations
interesting question I'm as you may be
aware there are numerous technologies
now that have been developed to perform
what may be referred to as genome
editing whereby individual mutations can
either be introduced or corrected using
a variety of different techniques
including increasingly now Chris Berg
cast nine technologies those have been
considered actually for therapeutic
applications more recently but there are
a variety of different companies that
have have a spouse that technology as a
therapeutic platform including metalia
which is a company that we work with
closely to bring a genome editing based
technologies to the forum
I would like to once again thank dr.
doing for his presentation do you have
any final comments for us today well I'd
like to thank everybody for tuning in
and thanks again to the organizers for
the invitation to talk to you a little
bit about our work and please feel free
to reach out to us if you have any
questions or are interested in
collaborating with us on human genetic
studies thanks again this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over and to get your credits
click on the c/e button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through November 11
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you in this webcast will
be available for replay we invite you to
afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye